listen was definitely the biggest loser
on last night during the premiere of the
new season of The Bachelorette oh my
goodness we were introduced to the man
now being called the worst contestant
ever Ryan M the junkyard specialist he
was actually asked to leave during the
first episode and here's why because the
video doesn't lie honey's I'm home I'm
horned up everybody that doesn't mean
you can touch Kaitlyn and appropriately
or say this the wasted contested then
gets put on blast and responds with this
threat why am I not raving right now
why is rape you're gonna support I
really think it's best to be go home
Ryan gave et this statement today quote
I wasn't interested in Caitlyn but was
interested in Brits I felt it was
obvious Brit wasn't going to be the one
so I just started being entertaining and
got way too drunk and get this he
reportedly dated Nikki Farrell who also
dated Bachelor villain Juan Pablo
weekend right didn't work out well
joining us right now is Chris Harrison
live from New York City so Chris this is
actually the first time in Bachelorette
history that you have actually kicked
somebody off would that feel like it was
like at first I thought he'd be kind of
adversarial and I thought you know who
knows what's gonna happen this guy might
punch me in the face but when he came
out and he saw me on the front porch and
he kind of realized what was gonna
happen he just kind of sunk and I
honestly felt a little bad for the guy
tonight is the second night of the
premiere and also we will find out which
Bachelorette stays and which one goes
the men have voted how do you feel about
it really was a house divided
really so it comes down to being really
close it was a very close vote it
definitely was you know I'm such a big
fan of the show I heard that Nick vile
from andis season is coming back to be
one of the bachelors is that true
interesting man if that's true that
would be one of the most dramatic
moments ever so yeah that would be good
I like him I look quick can we focus on
you for a second and you have enough
about the show let's talk about me about
you you have a nuam novel it's called
perfect letter it is supposed to be
passion fueled and suspense driven what
inspired you to write a book really it
was a an odd chance meeting in an
evening I spent with Nicholas Sparks of
course you know the Godfather of this
genre that kind of no pun intended
sparked the interest in writing you know
fictional romance you know give the
bachelor fans more of what they want
it's escapism it's romance its intrigue
and drama and that's all in the pages of
the perfect letter mrs. Frasier will
report on that Chris hey joining us by
the way everybody tomorrow the
Bachelorette either Caitlyn or Britt
we'll be right here on the set
you